this year the GPM market has been all
over the place with Nvidia and AMD GPUs
being way overpriced
we thought that immediate new turns here
to solve this issue but it really didn't
do it anything there is some hope from a
video with their possible new GTX I
loved 60 maybe even a new hold 1100
series without raytrace technology
included in it but what about AMD side
of things anybody did not launch a new
600 series this year but they did launch
a new 590 which is pretty much
equivalent to the rx 580 but that is
pretty much just a mid-level card as for
the higher range and Eve eiga just
really isn't cutting it
it is a lot more power hungry and not as
powerful as invidious cards however
aimed in Navi has received a lot of hype
suggesting that he'll perform really
well for a low price
similar to how Ryan did in the CPU
market so here's what the leaks suggest
[Music]
welcome to Horus Horus alright so first
let's take a look at all of the new GPUs
that are rumored to be launching first
of all anybody seems to be copying
medias naming scheme with the new cards
rumored to be named the Ark's 30 60 30
70 and 38 amy has done this numerous
times in the past with their ex 299
motherboards and rise in 3 5 7 and
possibly even 9 in the future so this
new naming scheme may be legitimate
starting off with the rx 3060 it is
rumored to have performance on the level
of the soon-coming 20 50 or current
NVIDIA GTX 1060 so basically we can
expect this card to be very similar to
the arcs 580 and 590 which are really
good mid-level GPUs the Oryx 3060
supposed to be based on na'vi 12
come with 4 gigabytes of ddr3 and have a
TDP of 75 watts the best part is that it
is only supposed to cost 130 dollars as
for the higher level rx 3070 it is
rumored to have performance on the level
of the unreleased
2060 or current 1070 so this card will
be very similar to Vega 56 this card is
also supposed to be
Noby 12 come with 8 gigabytes of video 6
memory and have a TDP of 120 watts again
the price supposed to be really really
good at $200 ask for the top-end rx 3080
this card is rumored to have performance
on the level of the new 2070 or the
current GTX 280 this card is supposed to
be just slightly faster than Vegas 64 at
15% faster
this card is supposed to be based on a
v10 come with 8 gigabytes of ddr2 6
memory and have a TDP of 150 watts and
of course the price had both been very
favorable at $250 which is half the
price of the 2070 it is even $150
cheaper and the cheapest today's that
you can find in my opinion this is
absolutely the best thing that we can do
because AMD is clearly not superior to
Nvidia in terms of technology they are
also working on ray-tracing technology
but they simply don't have that crazy
yet acknowledge that NVIDIA has or are
working on the high level GPUs and video
art but there is a clear place that AMD
can excel which is price so as a media
is trying to force ray-tracing
technology AMD could simply take their
current cards put it on a new
architecture have paired up with some
faster RAM and take out the unnecessary
retro technology which will make it a
lot cheaper and really put a dent in the
market this will introduce some solid
competition to the GPU market and India
will hopefully react better than Intel
especially considering that their stock
price has happened last 6 months
originally navi was rumored to come out
in the end of 2018 but 2018 is pretty
much over so that's clearly not
happening there are some rumors that are
suggesting that AMD will reveal navi at
CES this year however we haven't heard
anything from AMD so I'm not really sure
about that last time we saw AMD launched
Vega in the summer and it has only been
a year and a half since I release so AMD
may very well wait for this summer and a
completion of two years in cerulean Vega
to release AMD and AVI
however given the current market
situation and the fact that ain't even
think I really isn't doing very well in
the first place
MD may just go ahead and reveal Navi as
the
yes so Navi may very well be on the
horizon and be the rising of GPUs so
what do you guys think about all of this
are you guys more excited for AMD na'vi
or nvidia is rumored gtx 1160 make sure
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and be
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like to get them ready to drop
a light and consider subscribing if you
like to see more videos just like this
one but until then I'm Hari I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
[Applause]